Pease wealth and safety are just some of
the privileges children here enjoy
another is a huge range of options for
daycare facilities one of the trends is
preschools in nature far away from the
hustle and bustle of the concrete jungle
these kids are turning the woods into a
playground the hillside provides a
natural slide pieces of wood are great
for carving and juicy yellow plums along
the way are a welcome morning snack
every day they explore the forest on the
outskirts of the German capital Berlin
four-year-old Vivat has been
participating for the past two years and
today she's been allowed to join the
group of older kids for the first time
her mother says there's no better place
for a child to develop when I lived in
the city I was shocked at what my kids
were always picking up from the ground I
felt like they shouldn't touch anything
everything was kind of disgusting or
dirty or full of cigarette butts or
garbage and dog poo I always had the
feeling I had to hold them back there
was no natural place for my kids to
develop in the city the kids go outside
and all seasons regardless of the
weather
there's no scheduled routine instead the
day is filled with the children's
discoveries at the moment they're
learning how to use hand tools and thais
appleís has been working here for 14
years as a preschool teacher he knows
that going to the woods is good both for
the children's minds and their bodies
the obvious our aim is to give them a
sense of mindfulness that they can
communicate to other children to tell
them things like why kill that bug why
step on the nettles they're important
for the snails when the Sun comes out
snails can hide behind the leaves and
butterflies lay their eggs on them or
look at this plant you can eat it don't
destroy it it's important to us a trip
like this to the forest can be pretty
exhausting around midday the kids head
back to base they even have their own
shelter to relax in during the winter
they warm up here at the campfire if it
gets really cold they can move into the
nearby house plastic toys aren't allowed
but there are always plenty of
activities to keep them busy and
sometimes special guests come to visit
the neighbors sheep come here looking
for food on the property the RAM died so
it was buried here there's an
appreciation for everything even when
the kids are exploring and taking dead
animals apart there's still respect and
I believe that this respect for nature
and its creatures will transform into
respect for other human beings as well
as a sense of responsibility for the
environment 4 year old vivid really
enjoyed her first day in the older
children's group and she and the other
kids are already looking forward to
their next adventure in the forest